the layer heil pancho sponsored by step finance
your go to d5 portfolio manager on solana
luna if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh punch
show today is going to be a lot of fun because
we are talking about entrepreneurship and
building in crypto all of my favorite things
but before we jump into it i do want to let
you know that this is sponsored by blockfi as
usual so you can actually get amazing interest
rates right now i think actually they are the
most competitive with around nine percent on your
stable coins um i use them i really like them so
if you are interested i have left a link for you
in the comments and in the description so just um
check that out i think you get around 250 when you
sign up and this is powered by icon plus capital
the bc firm so definitely check them out all
right as i said we are talking entrepreneurship
we are talking crypto and a little bit of web3
so joining me today is the ceo of package portal
it is jg hey welcome to the show how you doing
doing very well thank you thank you for having me
yeah i'm really excited to chat with you i haven't
been covering a lot of web three so i'm really
happy to have you on um because i know you're
building in web3 um i don't fully understand
everything so i'm excited to learn and go into
it so you're essentially tokenizing e-commerce
what does that mean explain that to me yeah so
i guess high-level overview um we started out
tokenizing just delivery signatures i don't know
if you're familiar with a signature if you get
a package delivered to your house you have to
sign for it if it's expensive uh there's a fee
attached to that and it averages five to six
dollars and i own a delivery company here in
phoenix um i've owned it for about nine years
it's still operational my brother-in-law runs
it for me right now so i can focus on package
portal um but out of that i figured out i lost
a lot of money and so did my my staff i've
got about 40 drivers and we generated 600 000
in 2019 in signature fees and got none of it
the broker kept it all the middleman kept it all
and uh this was about a year after i had learned
of crypto uh one of my drivers actually told me
uh about a token that will remain unnamed uh that
he flipped for a whole lot of money and i was all
ears i knew about the profit potential of bitcoin
and other cryptos but i didn't really understand
smart contracts so once i dug down the rabbit hole
of of the power of automating middleman i figured
out we can you know let's automate this process we
can put a scanner in the hand of the consumer so
that they can close that supply chain loop and and
provide a digital signature that's you know it was
timely with covet um no contaminants you know with
the flu whatever it may be you can you can avoid
touching somebody else's device right so that
was kind of the uh the foundational core service
but from that we were able to um just expand a
whole lot of feature sets like the feedback data
consumer data is very valuable we know that big
tech minds this off of us right they they listen
they monitor they watch um they aggregate all of
your data and then they package it up and sell it
to advertisers so what we want to do is flip that
and say you as a consumer your data is valuable
and we want to reward you immediately in the
moment for that data and you know we can wrap it
up in the form of a token and you can do whatever
you want with that earn satoshi swap out just
add value to the consumer immediately and then
the merchants who want to access that data can
come on and and you know gain membership to the
platform effectively buying the tokens from the
uh the consumers are earning them so in on like a
really basic level you're trying to revolutionize
the delivery service industry is that right
absolutely yeah uh i think that delivery as
a whole it's a transport service right the the
economy is built off of consumers and merchants
somebody wants to sell something somebody
wants to buy it they agree on the price
and the transaction is conducted but e-commerce
changes that it introduces a whole new dynamic
of transportation um and that's where i come from
is logistics and so we have consumed all power
logistics company is just a third-party middleman
right they're a service provider but what happens
now is the merchant gives them their money
for the fee gives them their product and then
just crosses their fingers and hope everything
goes well and then wait two weeks before they
fulfill invoices just to wait for complaints
and damage reports but in that the carrier has
consumed all power they house the data and they
don't need to the data should be between the
consumer and the merchant and this this company
can just transport just get it from a to b
and that's what we hope to do and you mentioned
ernie satoshi's which was really cool which is
one of the reasons why i wanted to have
this conversation because i love anything
like that so how how does a customer how
does somebody like me on satoshi's so
it's possible right now currently i mean we just
launched v2 which is a rebuild version of our
initial launch um right before thanksgiving so you
can go and download the app right now and in the
play store the app store and then immediately if
you get packages that you as you have deliveries
come into your house you can input those tracking
numbers monitor it you'll get notifications
by this location and its status and then when
it arrives you can give a confirmation and then
thumbs up thumbs down kind of like uber uber
you rate it and then you can give customized
feedback too you know lipstick melted box was
damaged the driver was dirty you know the box
was not there um all sorts of customized
data points that the merchant can specify
if it's a you know food prep company that's
that's sending meals out they might want to know
was the ice melted or oh wow so wait a minute so
you can answer hershey's by essentially reviewing
how the delivery service went exactly yeah
because again you as the consumer that's very very
valuable data right but you can be rewarded for
that not just you know do it i get i get emails
all the time after a post purchase experience and
they want my survey i'm not going to provide that
because it's 45 seconds to load your web page and
then click through all this stuff with no benefit
to me as a consumer you can refine your business
processes and figure out ways to make more money
off of me and everybody else but i get nothing
so we want to flip that and say the the consumer
should have the power they should have more
power during the delivery experience and they
should have a voice in that and they should earn
um incentives for providing any sort of insight
yeah i mean everybody right now in the industry
is trying to build something with web3 which
essentially brings the power back to the people
it rewards them for their data and it flips it as
you say but like how long until you see this going
mainstream because it all sounds really great you
know even when we talk about like decentralized
social media platforms and everything that's
going on right now we all really want to have
that kind of decentralized experience where big
tech isn't monetizing us um but how long you know
until this whole idea is going to go mainstream
well i think we hit an inflection point sometime
in the last few months we've been building since
2019 so it's trendy now to say web 3 which is
just a really clever rebrand of crypto um you
know uh it works out really good so we're web
we have web3 solutions but i think that i think
it's here institutions are are onboarding they
want they want in they're buying nfts um they're
going heavy and long on bitcoin which is good you
know any dip that you see don't expect it to last
um it's it's here well what we all we've
been in crypto for a number of years and
and we all fantasized about institutional buy-in
and mainstream adoption and that sort of thing
and that's really what drove me to start this
company uh in 2018 i got in right at the top
uh the previous top and so i was putting money in
and just watching a dwindle and rather than just
you know sit on my thumbs and watch the portfolio
melt away i figured it's still very early what can
we do what can we build i'm not a coder i'm not
a software engineer um but i'm an entrepreneur
i know how to find people who can do things
build things connect the dots that i can't and
together we can accomplish some really cool stuff
i absolutely love that um you know a lot of people
get really salty and upset during a bear market um
but you went in at the top and you said i'm gonna
build which is amazing um but you're entirely
bootstrapped right yeah absolutely yeah so again
i own a delivery company so i had a lot of free
time i could i could focus on the biz dev um but
my engineers they all had day jobs my co-founder
he's uh he's been a software programmer for over
a decade has led two teams through acquisitions in
previous companies really experienced team leader
and he's got two guys that were working with
him in his previous company and for two years
they were nights and weekends and we launched the
product after a year and a half of testing and so
we had a beta out there for about a year nights
and weekends and it was tough uh we had explosive
growth during that time and it was hard to manage
uh but you know effectively nobody was taking the
salary it was just operational costs we would
we would front that and do what we needed to do
and then at one point we were able to uh use
some of the treasury tokens and and capitalize
a little bit there was a price run up um because
we do have an altcoin i don't want to talk about
it i want to respect the show and talk about
you know the entrepreneurship but we were able
to conservatively capitalized you know we we
uh we we took a little bit out for operational
uh expenses and and now we're good we have capital
we have runway the guys all went full time back
in june and and with six months of full-time build
time they were able to launch a completely rebuilt
product front and back and we have merchant
services so a merchant can go on to uh
our website or our app and view and aggregate
all of this data thumbs up thumbs down we can
isolate in the chicago area here's everybody who
said they had a bad experience and here's why
um here's all the a heat map of all of the
scans from a particular ship or flipkart in
india um you know we've got a lot of users
globally india indonesia netherlands are you in
the uk yet oh yeah gdpr yeah oh very good that's
amazing yeah of course uk regulation is a bit of a
nightmare at the moment when it comes to this but
i think that's so i think that's so exciting and
i think that you know it's people struggle very
much to try and find their place in the industry
um in the crypto space right they're like you
know what am i am i a trader am i an investor am i
trying to build something how do i build something
so my question is you know how did you um
kind of just like take the plunge into building
something in crypto right because like this is so
on the forefront of innovation um you know totally
leading the way i mean everything that's going on
with tech right now so how did you make that
decision i think effectively i was just trying
to solve my own problem because again i lost
a lot of money in in my delivery company 600k
in a year now that's nothing to sneeze
at because the middleman was taking them
taking the signature fee is that right yeah the
service is to collect the signature and that's
just it's just they call it a uh so quick
history lesson or i guess synopsis is is
within the industry there's proof of delivery
anytime you have a package come to your door
the courier can scan that and he's just capturing
the gps location and the time stamp and that's it
so effectively it's just some random fourth or
fifth party who's contracted and says i put that
tracking label at that place at that time and
that's where the buck stops that's not good enough
and so a signature can provide proof or
confirmation that somebody at that location
actually signed now signature can be forged
right drivers with covid uh you can look it
up online fedex all of the majors everybody
put out press releases and said we will no
longer collect signatures and drivers were doing
authorized forgery effectively they'll show you
at the door and i'll just put an x here by your
name um and that's kind of standard now oh wait
so because obviously i know that i remember
i remember during covered they wouldn't do
signatures because they didn't want to like
have that contact so they would just like
ring the doorbell leave the package so are you
saying that these drivers would forge signatures
well i don't want to i don't want to you know
okay on anybody in particular but yes that that
happens and this in a lot of cases it's authorized
because the the courier company has said just put
an x you know but that's not good enough because
a driver can put an x and not drop the package off
that is completely susceptible to you know
manipulation and fraud and on top of that somebody
is paying a fee for a service to be completed
that is not being completed so if there's a
five dollar like six dollars and 20 cents is
dhl for a signature it's 555 for ups and um
the the usps here in america they're the cheapest
um you know two dollars and 35 cents if you do it
online but that's still it's a fee tacked on to
show that you did what i already paid you to do
it's a confirmation you know i just want
my receipt you know and so we change proof
of delivery and we offer proof of receipt which
is putting that scanner that final uh the final
input the final data point from the consumer who
opened the supply chain loop in the first place
right you have the shopping cart moment and you
uh the consumer opens up that loop and then it
goes through order processes and then it finally
arrives at this destination and somebody else
who has no interest in either the brand or the
consumer they just want their their delivery fee
or their hourly wage and they just want to get
their route done so there's there's a disconnect
there so what we do is we connect the merchant and
the consumer at that moment of delivery which is a
very powerful moment you can capture their eyes
and their thoughts what do you think about this
product um would you like to buy more what
else do you want to buy advertisements that
sort of thing there's lots that we can
do when we reconnect them at that moment
i like that you i think that's what most
entrepreneurs do right they decide to
create the idea comes from the fact that they
had a problem and they are trying to solve it
um and so i think i think that's so fascinating
it just no matter what industry that's always the
case so talk to me about some of the biggest
challenges you had um building in crypto
um well i think regulatory uncertainty is is the
biggest cloud that hangs over us like how do we
how do we go about these different things in a
way that's not going to wrap a noose around us in
the future or bring bring trouble and so we did a
lot of due diligence we have a legal team that is
heavily in in the space and uh they're
working on some good things for us but
that that was you know it's more of a concern that
didn't necessarily make it difficult it made it a
little bit more tedious because we have to examine
every different aspect um i guess difficulty is
the ux really because the user experience in
crypto you know it's not good we got to find
that and that's something that we're working on
trying to do we really want to um make it easy
for people to get crypto right ultimately bitcoin
i think that that will become the global reserve
of store value it's going to replace gold why not
it's better 10 times better in every every way
um so if i believe that to be the case there's a
transfer of wealth coming and i want to i want to
empower the people effectively so our our app is a
tool it's like if bitcoin is the uh the gold rush
then our app is picks and shovels and we
want to empower people to go out and mine
it for themselves rather than being
mined for your data and your value
by big tech go out and mine this this new
coming um store value for yourself how did you
how did you get into crypto i don't know what
get into crypto oh one of my uh one of my drivers
he started working for me and he told me i
remember an unnamed token i don't want to name it
yeah he told me how you turn which token was that
tron that was tron yeah yeah he said i turned 1500
into 40k and i was like really tell me more um but
that that spun me down the rabbit hole of um the
tech i i because i knew about the profit making
you know i was a little bit concerned there was
a lot of fun at that time in 2017 and so i was
kind of hands off uh but i did my due diligence
find out that wasn't the token i wanted um there
were other tokens i wanted ultimately bitcoin is
what you want and i want to put it in the hands of
other people so you know why not arm them with the
ability to do so monetize your feedback your data
your input your thoughts how do you feel about
the products you buy and the places that you
buy them from and that's very powerful tools
for the merchants and the brands because they can
look at that aggregate and and just make their
stuff better yeah and i think sometimes like
when you do building crypto and you know you
build whatever it is you're building whether
it's just like your own brand whether it's
uh whether you know whether it's you're investing
in your trading you do get a lot of backlash um
so i'm just wondering have you had any backlash
from i don't know when you try i don't know any
any backlash from whether it's like colleagues
family friends what kind of issues have you faced
and i i don't think we had a lot of backlash um we
were i mean it's been a blessing you know we had
a great reception from a particular community we
built our back end processes our smart contracts
on the zilliqa platform which is the first public
network to have sharding which makes transactions
pretty fast and scalable and cheap there are
other cheaper options out there right now but
you know they have centralization issues and every
network has its own problems um we don't want to
be tribalistic so our back end exists there but
we want to uh deploy uh the ability for users
to earn credits and rewards and tokens on their
own favorite network we don't want to have tribes
fighting and we only be isolated to one chain if
you love bitcoin and you want to just scan for
stats we want to make that happen if you want to
convert into solana or avax or ether any number of
tokens phantom if you want to have those tokens
because every token or every um i guess smart
contract layer one protocol has its own community
and rather than alienate any one community we
want to make it feasible for everybody to uh you
know enjoy the ability to monetize their feedback
that's interesting so how how is that possible
so you're the backend is entirely on zilliqa
is that right right so what happens is is
you know when you confirm and deliver you
you you go through the process of the app uh
you get credits and you can then claim them as
we have a kyc process um to make sure that we
we stay in bounds and and um that's working
very good for us yeah got to be compliant um
but that will authorize your wallet and then
you're able to claim a token that you can then
convert into other tokens um and and so we have
on the pipeline right now making that much easier
and wrapping up the gap because right now the
challenge there is gas getting silica
is hard particularly here in america
um and we don't want new uses why is it
hard in america it's just not it's not all
coinbase um we don't have access to finance
uh we have like there's only a few exchanges
and getting crypto is hard period full stop right
uh you got to go through this huge kyc process
and um that's troublesome man you've been
in it for a while you you're an evangelist
you're doing a great job of being ambassador for
for crypto and bitcoin in particular and we want
to do the same thing but it's hard because trying
to get people to understand how to create a wallet
and secure the private key and not and secure
the private key again you know be very safe
there um and then operate and trade and swap
and do all these things it's very complicated
for for people that are not native to this system
and we want to make that easy because we believe
we can be an onboarding platform for people
in the crypto rather than having to figure
all that out and go and buy it just tell us how
you felt about your purchase and you can earn it
so when they oh i see so when they are involved
they there is it's like using a cus it's like
using a custodian right like there is no
private key there is no there is no seed
phrase there is no like serious responsibility or
self-classy that needs to be taken is that correct
no currently we are non-custodial so we we want
users to oh non-custodial yeah we don't want to
control that we want users to be able to if
you earn a reward we want you to own it you
know and do what you want trade it swap it hold
it stake it we have all of those options for you
um right now you can turn it into sats satoshi's
but there's you know like five different steps
and three different exchanges you have
to do that on and so we need to fix that
that's our that's our goal for h1 we'll be at the
blockchain or the bitcoin conference in miami and
and maybe we'll have some progress there that we
can share but yeah ultimately ultimately we want
to make it much easier because currently to claim
or convert or do any of that you've got to have
gas and on ethereum nobody is going to be able
to claim any tokens at those gas prices silica
enables us to do so for much cheaper it's a few
pennies but still you know at scale that's not
good we cannot just front the gas so we've
got some different contract standards that
we're looking to deploy in the coming weeks and
months to to make the user experience just much
better so that a new user can earn crypto claim
it and then do whatever they want immediately
speaking of ethereum i tried to sell on nfc
yesterday and it was going to cost me 200 i was
like i'm gonna wait for a higher offer like that
was crazy it's so insane i know um but you make a
really important point in that like these taking
self-custody is so complicated for people that
don't understand seed phrase private keys like
understanding you know good self custody practices
what is it like the concept of a wallet you know
is even complicated so how how do you how do you
on board people then because like obviously the
idea is great um you get rewarded for leaving a
review which i think is just amazing um i wish we
could i wish we got rewarded on uber for leaving a
review the amount of ubers i take um i literally
never put in say that again who said patent
pending um yeah no it's true it's true i never
leave a review i actually never leave reviews
because why you're not devised to do so yeah
you're not benefited in any way shape or form
and it just takes time away from you yes exactly
so like i love the idea i'm just thinking you know
how is the average person going to understand
this and on board them their self themselves
and and that's that's at the height of our our
discussions and our our strategy overall our
number one goal this year is is to expand and get
more users because ultimately it makes the the
economy the ecosystem more more resilient and more
valuable and and strengthens and hardens the the
value proposition that we bring to merchants and
it's you know it's synergistic but it's difficult
so um currently our focus is people who are crypto
natives they understand how to do some of the the
bare essentials and then we plan to we're going
to open a seed round here probably this quarter
um and then try to scale up the team to be able
to deploy to multiple multiple layer ones and
then as well as just improve the overall
user experience because we want it to be
super simple for somebody to to come in and also
we have educational materials within the app and
we're going to build that out you so you can come
to the app similar to like a coin base and things
like that because we do where the responsibility
of if if we can succeed on our goals then we
have the propensity to become a very powerful
onboarding platform for non-crypto natives to
get into the space and that's a responsibility
that we're not going to take lightly we want to
educate them and equip them to navigate safely um
and not step on any landmines you know we want to
shepherd them in that way i have a question just
like about um motivation because i've been um
reading a lot online um about people struggling to
remain motivated when they're building businesses
right um so where does your where does
your passion and your motivation come to
build that's a good question i'm i'm
super competitive that's my little brother
he is a retired army vet retired firefighter
anesthesiologist with his own practice real
estate agent great guy and you know we we compete
against each other for for that but also my father
uh he was in a wheelchair he had an illness when
i was 12 he went to the hospital and was gone five
months we left our house moved in with my grandma
and it was it was quite the experience right but
he was an entrepreneur he before that before his
accident he had us out there delivering newspapers
and yellow pages people don't remember that it
was like google it was a four inch google on
paper yellow pages at like age of nine in in ten
um and so i've always had that drive to want to
not work for somebody else and not be tired not
be trading my time for a set wage but exerting
my energy and getting recumbents for that like you
know in in uh in parallel with my efforts and so
it's it can be hard sometimes as an entrepreneur
especially when you you hit slaughters values and
peaks and you just gotta go back to your uh your
original motivations your original inspiration
why did you want to build this in the first place
and if that was vain and there was nothing there
if it was superfluous then you're not going
to have anything to fall back on and you you
might not be able to continue but if you had a
solid foundation for wanting to start something
then then you can succeed and in my case you know
my pops was in a wheelchair running an insurance
company from the bedroom and doing taxes and this
kind of stuff still getting it not stopped by
the loss of his legs and so i want to i want to
honor that legacy and go out and you know start
something and make it great it's always good to
have a good example um but it's funny because it's
funny because like a lot of people um talk about
how the nine to five is the safest option right
and i was watching a video yesterday actually um
it was jim carrey speaking saying that his father
wanted to be a comedian um and he said that he
he said but it was too risky so he went and got a
nine to five when jim carrey was then 12 years old
his father lost his safe job and so like he would
have been safer going ahead and you know building
something and chasing his dreams so yeah it's very
scary i mean you have to take a lot of risk you
effectively i mean it's it's akin to taking your
own sovereignty over finances right when you
become your own custodian of your your wealth
yeah then that's a big responsibility it's on
your shoulders and it's similar with with uh
entrepreneurship you've got to take risk it might
cost you some money it's going to cost you some
time that's for sure mental capacity vacations
all kind of stuff that you might want to do
you can't because you need to accomplish these
goals if you want to succeed um but yeah overall
i mean it's a fun game do you think that nine to
five is is really that safe or do you feel safer
no i don't i mean my my previous nine to five
before i before i uh like i had a i was managing
warehouse um furniture warehouse and i was i
was good i was good at my job i was efficient my
reward for getting done sooner than everybody and
and doing a better job than everybody was grunt
work now i just gotta you gotta you gotta wait you
got two hours left on your shift so go sweep the
floors no my value is worth more than that i you
know i'm outperforming everybody and there was no
incentive for me to perform better and so i
i can see the flipped model of that with my
delivery company because i don't pay my drivers
hourly they all earn piece work effectively every
delivery that they do they earn two dollars or
more um and some of them are doing 250 stops a day
um on some days so they're making good money
um but they're incentivized to do so when i got
into it the the more you take the more you make
and the sooner you do it the sooner you go home
so there's incentive there and that's that
changes everything and there's no there's not much
incentive with nine to fives unless it's climbing
that corporate ladder um for the purpose of
you know just being elevated or for the purpose
of gleaning knowledge and learning what you can
from those different roles and then applying it
to something in the future there's value there
but yeah i mean you make you make an you make an
interesting point and that you know you worked
super efficiently better than everyone else
so then your last like three hours of the day
you had to do grunt work and you're just like i
could be spending my time more efficiently it just
it doesn't really make sense there's no it's
just a continuous cycle and then i often find
and i hope no one like gets offended by this but
i also find like when when that's the case and you
know you're not building for you you're building
for somebody else and there's no direct incentive
i often find like the work done is never as good
as it would be if you had an incentive to do it
for yourself or even if you had an incentive
to make more money right like but just because
you finished your work faster doesn't mean you're
going to make more money absolutely it comes down
to ownership i mean as an owner you you put risk
and skin into the game and so if you don't perform
well you you might lose a contract and that
sort of thing you're going to lose out um it's
different with the 9 to 5 when you're working for
somebody else and they're just paying you hourly
that's just not there yeah it's true it's it's uh
it's an interesting interesting way of doing it um
i i did some work with them some people
that worked at their nine to fives and
they they hated their job and there was no
incentive to provide good quality service
um so it kind of just ties back to the whole
idea with package portal and that you know you
are directly incentivized um because you want to
you know you every there's an incentive in every
way yeah incentive is everything and and you know
there's a lot of value i don't want to disparage
nine to fives because i learned a lot in the ones
that i worked they were hard a lot of them were
not rewarding at all financially but um you know
the lessons that i learned and the work ethic
that it that it forced and ingrained within me was
valuable but ultimately it's it's i don't like to
use dead end but it's a it's a cul-de-sac because
you cannot take ownership you can't control your
destiny you are effectively um you know you're
joining somebody else's mission and that's cool
for a time but me you know being the com
competitor that i am and wanting to achieve and
and control my own destiny and my schedule
um and get maximum value out of my efforts
and my energies because i think that they can
provide value then i want to pursue that and
and you can't do that working for somebody else
you just have to do it yourself yeah for sure
like i don't want to discredit that either
um i just for me i just think it's dangerous
i just think it's dangerous um especially with
inflation right like the uk today is just hit
its highest um level of inflation um in 30 years
i think it's that five i know it's at 5.4 percent
and that's just a shy number if you don't include
the um the cpi and so you know you can't turn
around and up your prices according to inflation
whereas you can when you're an entrepreneur
mm-hmm yeah you have total flexibility you can do
it when you can set the prices change the prices
if there's customers that you just want to give
a smoking deal to you can do that you control it
um and that gives you a lot of power in
sales and communication and networking
and really it's just about taking on
that risk so that you can absorb power
um and it's a lot of work you know it not to shy
away from from the long nights and weekends and
the energy mental taxation i was not just great
i'm only i just turned 22. i'm just kidding
five years no i just turned 40. um and my hair's
black on top but it's you know it's right here
and some of that stress is from entrepreneurship
having within the logistics space as well every
package needs to be delivered every day it
doesn't matter if this guy breaks down or
his he's having a baby or she's sick none of that
matters i still got to get these packages out
um so again ownership even when it gets hard you
got to figure out a way to get it done that's my
motto let's figure it out when there's a problem
or a challenge let's figure it out it's true um
and how do you stay then like ahead of the game
and stay innovating and stay creating because like
for me personally i do like that's the challenge
that i find um you always want to be trendy
you know as trendy as possible you want to be
at the forefront of innovation you want to be
really like yeah trendy is the word so
how do you keep creating and innovating
that's a good question it kind of links back to
the motivation i think that if you're solving
a problem for people then you're going to stay
relevant you're going to stay trending and stay
in the moment because people want what you have
or what you provide and ultimately what we provide
is is a marketplace for them to monetize their
data and monetize their feedback which is huge
and then so so that's benefit for them big value
ad but then conversely the merchant um if they're
paying six dollars for a signature fee right now
they can get it for like a nickel you know much
less than 97 savings or something to that effect
but also they can engage with their consumers in
a whole new new way so it's major value for
the merchant major value for the consumer
um it's it's synergistic and and beneficial for
both parties and we that gives us confidence
we can stand behind that we're saying we're
not here to siphon value away from one party
um whether it be to line our own pockets
or um just to help somebody succeed at the
expense of another we don't want that we want to
decentralize power effectively carriers right now
like we said at the top of the car carriers have
all power they control the data and they're biased
it's all in a silo they're biased if there's a
problem they can obfuscate or hide that from you
right if there's no problem if everything goes
good one time they'll amplify that i have no
insight even my delivery company i provide data
and i have to pay my broker to access that data
and no consumer i've ever delivered to in all
of my time has been able to look at that data
and we need to change that the merchants should
be able to own their data and the consumer should
generate it sounds very web too sounds like the
mainstream media and everything that's going on
hiding hiding information amplifying break it
down i mean it should be transparent um public
you know we want we want merchants and consumers
to join you know to band together effectively to
hold carriers accountable to better service
and honest data yeah there's not a lot of
that sometimes so what advice would you give
people who are looking to um you know start
building something for themselves in crypto um
you know whether it's um whether it's working in
the industry full-time or whether it's actually
building some form of product like you've built
all right those are probably two different
approaches i think working on something full-time
find something that you're passionate about
and find a team that you can work well with
and that you're really ultimately a vision or a
product that you're excited about because when
your passion is there it's easy to work i love i
love what we built i think it's solving a lot of
problems it's huge i want to tell everybody do
you see how cool this is you know i want to be
calm but but i'm very passionate about it because
i know that it's it's providing value um and so if
you can align yourself with the team or a vision
or a product that is that fits you in that manner
um for you i think it's bitcoin you you've latched
yourself to like the coming revolution of of this
financial uh traditional financial market being
upended right and you're an evangelist for that so
it's easy you enjoy this i'm sure
yeah i'm a freedom maximalist
my sister lives in panama she sailed down from
maryland she's been there for about two years now
oh wow where abouts in panama i forget the
name of the city okay i've never been there
but i just remembered that um yeah yeah
yeah yeah freedom it's all about freedom
yeah freedom maximalist like i totally agree with
you i think when you do something which you truly
love and you feel that there's purpose in it then
you have to do it i hate the idea that you have to
monetize your hobbies right people often say
do something that you're good at and a lot of
people say no just you don't have to monetize
everything just be happy and enjoy it right
but at the same time like you should be what's
the point in working if it doesn't if there's
no end if it doesn't if it doesn't inspire you
to wake up every day like you don't want to be
living for the weekends you want to be you
know you want to wake up on a monday and
be like wow today i'm going to change the world
and like you know whether you're whether you're
directly changing the world or whether you're
you know just doing something on a small scale
i think it's so fulfilling you know and even just
like everything that's going on in the world right
now with lockdowns and things like that like it it
for me personally it just ties into crypto like it
just does and so it'll for me it will just makes
sense you know i agree and there's never been a
a better time in the history of man than to try
to seize on some of your dreams and your goals
and to take that leap and and add a little bit
of risk because i mean i think the internet is
powerful you can you can learn anything that
you want to you don't need a college degree
that costs a hundred thousand dollars you can
just go do your research and figure it out
because you know college degree does not give
you applied knowledge it gives you just learn
apply it sorry no but you know it speaks to the
to the uh the desires and the goals and if you
can find something that you're passionate about
um then it's easy you hear it all the time i've
heard it since i was a little kid oh i love what
i do so it's recent i'm not working yeah yeah
i'm not working because i love it you're still
working that's that's bs when i'm i'm dog tired
i gotta fire off an email this i got deadlines
this and that um and you can't drop the ball
there's calls that you don't want to take you
might not feel good you might have things going
on my dogs are going nuts they're driving me crazy
today you know my wife whatever the case may be
you want to you want to be able to take care of
your family and and do good work but sometimes
it becomes difficult however if you love what
you're doing you're passionate about what it is
like the end goal is the north star of the company
that you work for or the company that you start
then it becomes easy yeah i mean it it is an
interesting point there's no one else that's
going to do it other than you like for example
imagine if i was so sick today there's no one else
that's going to do this show that maybe i am sick
you wouldn't know i have to just have to turn up
just have to shut up yeah yeah exactly you got to
get it done yeah you know delivery every package
every day you got to get it done if the car breaks
down or or this happens we still got to do it
exactly you got to find a solution so what's
the future then of um package portal what can
we expect i know you said some educational
content could be coming um i know you said
that you want to make earning satoshi's easier
the user experience but what else can we expect
all right so much yeah i've got we've got a road
map on our on our twitter profile you can check us
out packageportal.com you can see that there also
um we've got a lot this year we've got nfts coming
and they will be utility-based yeah not just cool
art we'll have that but they're going to have
function to where you know if you own one of our
entities you don't just earn one reward you earn
three or five there'll be multiple multipliers
triple satoshis yeah you can earn five satoshi's
first scan and and a lot of cool stuff that we
can integrate with with the non-functional tokens
also direct support for multiple layer ones
and and satoshi's bitcoin itself um we've got
our legal team in wyoming i think i mentioned
them earlier they've been working on some stuff
we had a call with the secretary of state there
because we're incorporated in 2019 before web 3
was cool we've been here guys we've been working
with the secretary of state on some different
applications and they're really excited about the
utility of our token um like you know the most
definitive textbook case i don't want to speak for
them but um that's the vibe that we get that they
just they really could use us as an example for
um what a utility token should look like how to
operate and navigate going back to bootstrapping
we never did any otc sales we never did any icos
or raises or anything like that any token that we
ever swapped was through a dex um in conservative
amounts over time never when a price was dropping
to to preserve the economy because you want to
build a community and our community loves and
trust us they rode with us for a long time and we
love that and that's powerful for us because the
network effect is huge word of mouth is incredible
yeah no absolutely is so before we say
goodbye where can well actually first do
you have any like last final words that you want
to share with everyone ah go download the app um
send us a message if you need some help you
know we're excited to build i think that uh
we might become a little bit more publicized
in the coming weeks and months as we try to to
hit our goals and the objectives that we have just
to make it very easy for people to earn crypto and
then swap and trade and and do whatever they want
in d5 for delivery data web3 for e-commerce we
built it we're here and it's launched in this live
and now we just want to tell the world about it so
you might be able to go yeah we are early so where
can people um find you um what's the twitter tell
us everything everything is package portal one
word um spelled normally so twitter medium our
website uh anything it's all we got the rights
early so it's package supporter you can look
us up that way find us in the app store the google
play store you can download it start earning today
um yeah and guys don't forget follow jg on
twitter for um just to stay up to date and
from the jagged one yeah the giant one there
you go um i want to thank you so much it's been
so nice chatting with you um i love to have
a good conversation about you know building
entrepreneurship um removing middlemen becoming
more sovereign over everything that you do um
so i want to thank you so much it's been so great
having you on 100 yeah i love talking about this
stuff too it's easy you know sovereignty over your
finances over your time over your vision and goals
ultimately your life um and then if you align
that with doing something that adds value to the
world then then what's to stop you i totally agree
with you that's the perfect package so guys don't
forget follow jg follow package portal and don't
forget to tune in next week we'll see you then